[موسيقى]
بعدما يزيد على 30 عاما من التكهنات عثرت
اخيرا اطقم البحث في مكب بولايه نيو
مكسيكو الامريكيه على نسخ لعبه الفيديو اي
تي التي لاقت انتقادات واسعه بعيد انتاجها
في العام
1982 اللعبه حملت معها العديد من القصص
فهي صدرت في فتره كان فيها مجال العاب
الفيديو بدائيا حيث حصلت على لقب اسوا
لعبه في التاريخ لكن القصه الاشهر هي في
كيفيه تخلص شركه اتاري المنتجه لها من هذه
اللعنه حيث قامت بدفنها تحت الارض في مكان
مجهول بولايه نيو مكسيكو وتقوم حاليا شركه
مايكروسوفت بالعمل على انتاج فيلم يوثق
قصه التنقيب عن المئات من نسخ اللعبه التي
دفنت في صحراء نيو مكسيكو وبالفعل تم
العثور على ملايين النسخ والعديد منها كان
في وضع جيد يشار الى ان الفيلم الوثائقي
سيعرض هذا العام لمستخدمي اجهزه الاكس
بوكس